foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] them
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome to the show
[Music]
we have some special guests for you
today
[Music]
we are going to have
michael popock
from legal af
uh joining us uh in in just a bit to
talk about the
um the what's going on in the manhattan
da's office he should be joining us very
soon
and we also have an a special interview
for you guys today
bad brad berkwit of the bad brad
berkwith show
and also the ceo of ringside report
we're going to have all those things
today we're also going gonna do a little
bit of surfing the tweety tweets in the
trendy trends
and we're gonna try to watch some video
if we can stand it
[Laughter]
uh but the the next day this day
of the judge brown jackson hearings
um we've endured the last three days the
last two days have been josh holly
absolutely obsessed with child porn
and tom cotton too did you notice that
tom cotton and josh holly are
absolutely 100 percent obsessed can't
stop talking
they can't stop talking about it can't
stop talking about child porn
good morning we have mayo here good
morning
we have we have mj here good morning
good morning good morning good morning
everyone we have kathy
we have we we have david and they're all
rowing in here we have robin everyone's
here
uh good to see you guys here today we
again we got a special episode for you
today um let's let's not waste um
let's not waste too much time
um as we as we go through here you guys
know we've done we've done the pop-ins
and one that made it most popular most
famous was the one the only from legal
af podcast
michael popock with the pope poppin
michael pobach how are you sir
i'm doing great why why is my camera so
dark i don't know
i don't know
yeah tony i'm doing great so so i i have
a lot of questions for you we wanted i i
text you yesterday and i said hey this
manhattan d.a thing is is in the news
it's crazy um so i had a lot of
questions about
the manhattan da's
what's going on in that office because
it seems like there's a lot of drama
going on
if that's fair to say
so let's start from the top the
manhattan d.a opened up a criminal
investigation into the trump
organization correct
yeah they did both they did they did two
things the they worked in conjunction
with the
um new york attorney general leticia
james's office which is on the civil
side correct work working in conjunction
with the manhattan district attorney's
office
which was originally sy vance who is
retired and then now alvin bragg since
january 1st and they were working for
the last year and a half
overlapping in conjunction
people from the manhattan da's office
working closely with the
civil lawyers at the new york attorney
general's office and
we know what leticia james has been
doing because she has been filing in
court
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
pages
that explain where she is in the various
fraud civil fraud investigations
that she has
been conducting
issues but that's very typical for a
civil right to file that many documents
in court is that is that very typical
well not exactly i think she's been more
conscientious about the documentation
that she has filed to both justify the
investigation
and to respond through the court system
to the media blitz that the trumps and
the trumplets and all the trumpers you
know all his tweets and she feels
compelled and i don't blame her to put
to put together a shed load of material
and that's a legal term and file it not
a shitload of [ __ ] no shed
i would i would say [ __ ] load but you
know a shitload of material that's right
and you know
you don't know all the internal
confidential investigatory methods she's
using right but you know the results
that they're focused on the financial
statements that they're focused on
um improper fraudulent inflation of his
assets deflation of his assets in order
to secure tax abatements inflation of
his assets in order to borrow money
that's all front and center and she's
about to get the deposition of donald
trump and of uh donald jr anna ivanka
because
the new york
superior sorry supreme court justice
that's responsible for this has ordered
that they appear now he's taken a
uh trump has taken an appeal to the
first department first level appeal here
in manhattan
and and he's going to lose that and he's
going to have to sit for a deposition
now that's everything related to the new
york um attorney general who sits in
albany at in our state capitol and
that's the civil side of it not the case
it's a civil side she hasn't been
conducting a criminal side and
trump wants her to conduct a criminal
side because then he'll take you know he
wants her to drag him into the grand
jury but she's not conducting the grand
jury manhattan district attorney's
office which is for most people
understand that's been the model for
every law and order episode is based on
the manhattan district attorney's office
we had a change in guard at the
manhattan da's office so who was who was
who was the original d.a that opened
this case cyrus vance okay who comes
from a long well-considered political
family
um starting with his father and cybants
you know people have their own problems
with cybants but i always thought that
psy
was on the right side of justice and he
opened the in the criminal investigation
he hired
mark pomerantz who's the special
prosecutor i'm going to talk about with
you next who resigned in february he
hired the other there were two special
prosecutors mark pomerance was 70 and
came out of retirement to do this
full-time for a year and a half with sci
vance
psy vance
allowed them to develop their evidence
working with special investigators
talk to witnesses and open up a special
grand jury in order to present the
evidence to get an indictment
right at the moment
where
they weren't really ready to go into the
grand jury yet for the full indictment
they had witnesses going into the grand
jury the the the um time period for the
grand jury expired
sy vance extended it knowing that he'd
be leaving office in january to give the
new sheriff in town the new
uh attorney
manhattan district attorney alvin bragg
time to make his own prosecutorial
decision about whether to continue
because when you inherit a prosecution
fundamentally you still have to make
your own decision as to whether you
because the buck stops with you whether
you are going to prosecute that case so
so what you're saying is is that science
couldn't force uh alvin bragg who is the
new d.a to prosecute in other words once
that once the the sword is passed
you know now it is bragg's sword in
other words one thou you got it exactly
right the only other
wild hair here wild card here
is that there is one other person
that can influence a prosecution and a
prosecutorial decision other than ada in
a way other than the d.a and that is
the person that's sitting behind the
plaque that says governor of the state
of new york oh okay so cat so so kathy
ho cool who's our
uh act she's not even acting she's our
she's our governor of new york she's
running she's running for election
she has already been apprised of this
she has the right to replace
attorney generals uh and and manhattan
and district attorneys for the different
counties she can so what you're saying
what's the way you're saying is she can
just she can just pull a mulligan on
bragg
she can do one of two things she can
she's already met with him about the
case that's been reported to the media
gotcha she can give him a warning and
say
tell me
present the case to me i want to
understand the case
if the governor says alvin with all due
respect you should be prosecuting this
case and you should be bringing this to
the grand jury and alvin says i don't
want to
she has two choices she can either
replace him meaning she takes away the
will of the people because he was
elected with a very high percentage by
the people of the city of new york in
manhattan to be the d.a there
she can say i'm going to replace you on
this case and i'm going to assign a new
prosecutor in a new county to handle the
case because i don't think you're doing
your job or i could fire you and he
knows that he's he's been told and sh
and it's been reported in the media
that when when somebody interviewed her
three weeks ago and said well
governor you have the power to remove
the prosecutor right if you don't like
the job they're doing and her response
was very diplomatic but very chilling
she said i am well aware
of the powers of the governor
uh if you're alvin bragg that's not a
great right you know that's like an
owner of an nfl team about a coach you
know when they say well the coach's
record is terrible are you going to keep
them i'm well aware of my powers as the
owner of the team
i know his record and i know i know that
i can fire that person right
so so
but now alvin here's some let me
wrap it up quick here because you want
to get to mark pomerantz
february the 23rd there was a bombshell
in the trump
investigative criminal investigation
through the manhattan da's office in
that the two special prosecutors who
were deputized by alf by psy vance and
inherited by alvin bragg
resigned and they didn't just resign
quietly they resigned noisily
they did not release their resignation
letter they did not leak their
resignation letter right which i i have
part of it that i'll show here well it's
bit the new york times has a copy of it
not from pomeranz but has a copy of it
and ran with the story last night we
suspected so karen uh friedman agnifulo
might right other co-anchor on legal af
midweek who worked as the number two
underside vance in the manhattan da's
office we did a whole
twitter spaces back on february 23rd
when this bombshell came out where we
were shadow boxing and speculating a
little bit about what that letter of
resignation said but we said what what
has happened which it was the death
knell for the prosecution no matter what
alvin bragg said three days after the
resignations where he said no no i'm not
killing the prosecution i'm reassigning
it to some career prosecutors in our
office and we're still on the case
nobody really believes that everybody
believes that if pomeranz had walked out
the door we didn't know exactly why on
that day it was for some really good
reason where they had crossed the line
of his moral and professional um uh
boundaries and he decided he couldn't
take it anymore and left now we've
gotten the letter i don't know if you
want to put up a little bit yeah or read
from it yeah let's see if we can um uh
let me pull this down here
this is this is from pomerantz now who
who is mark pomerance so the audience is
clear on this so mark mark pomerantz is
a supremely well respected sort of a
lion of the bar in the in the city of
new york has been for the last 40 years
he is a white collar criminal defense
guru former prosecutor
a short list if you if you ever need i
sound like i'm doing an ad for mark
pomerance all right
short list if you ever got in trouble
with the federal or state government on
a prosecutorial side and needed a lawyer
by your side mark pomerance would be on
your list he would he can't he was
retired he came out of retirement
because sai vance asked him to take on
this very important role of being the
lead prosecutor in the office for trump
so you know
we thought when mark pomerance came on
the case that was terrible news for
trump because pomeranz is a pitbull and
he's known about it now there's one
other interesting link the media is sort
of glossed over but i'm going to break
it here on your show you ready [ __ ]
tony yeah i'm i'm ready let's break it
so so ron fascetti who is the lawyer for
donald trump donald trump and who
constantly
tweets out like trump about there's no
merit to the case there's no merit to
the case why are they prosecuting this
he was a law partner of pomeranz about
20 25 years ago so these two they know
each other they know each other really
well they were law partners i don't know
why they're no longer law partners but
they but they're law partners so they're
these two lions sort of you know
fighting it out over here um but
um i think that you want to put the
letter back up yeah yeah you want to
quote from part of it about
because this is i want to tell your your
listeners and followers this is not
normal it is not normal for the
prosecutor to put in his departing
resignation letter that he believes
there is sufficient evidence
why why is that not normal why is that
because
a prosecutors don't resign in protest
because their cases aren't being
prosecuted and when that happens they
don't write detailed letters that
because they don't become evidence one
day that'll be used with the defense so
what you're saying is this is possible
evident we're looking at possible
evidence that could be used in the
trials what you're saying well no but
it'll be used by freschetti to argue to
a judge that the case either has no
merit or that that there's a pomerantz
has some sort of axe to grind i see it
it'll be used against the prosecution
which is why prosecutors don't usually
write it i think pomerantz wrote it
a he's no dummy he knows it was going to
leak out at some point i don't think he
did it but certainly one degree or two
degrees moved from mark pomerance he
sort of looked the other way and let it
get out to the new york times
because it's because it hasn't leaked
for several weeks though i mean like for
a month right almost for a full month
but here it says quite clearly
donald trump has committed crimes under
the new york penal law related to his
financial dealings i as a prosecutor
believe that we can make out beyond a
reasonable doubt that he is guilty of
crimes he needs to be prosecuted and
alvin bragg your decision with all due
respect you know what comes next when
somebody says with all due respect with
all due respect alvin your good faith
belief that there's not enough evidence
to support this prosecution you're wrong
and this case should be prosecuted and i
am resigning in protest as it says here
i therefore resign effective immediately
good luck to you alvin and i think this
is now leaked with that and the governor
issue that we just talked about is going
to put pressure on alvin bragg to to to
do something about prosecuting trump but
then
what's for shetty going to say the trump
process the trump defense lawyer oh this
is political this is because he got
pressure because the new york times
article judge this whole thing is a
charade it should be dismissed so will
that make a big difference though will
that make a big difference it could
and and who who will that make a
difference too to a judge or judge right
and what what step is that because we're
not talking about going straight to a
jury and you know them having this this
this charade it would go to a judge
first right i mean which would make some
of those decisions
there's exactly right tony there's two
ways to do it and the one way i don't
think will be that successful because
they've tried it before where they file
a motion
for injunction
to stay the continued investigation and
prosecution even though there's been no
indictment so pre-indictment they go run
into this judge and say judge look at
this look at the circus that's been
created by mark parmerance and and this
letter and the new york times article
the whole thing should be dismissed and
you should stop
issuing an injunction to stop the
manhattan da's office from going any
further in the investigation i don't
think that's going to work but
what will happen is if alvin bragg now
you know to continue our inappropriate
sports analogies and metaphors starts
hearing footsteps
and decides maybe i should prosecute
this case
and and brings it to the grand jury with
the new prosecutor because pomeranz is
out never coming back this was napalm on
the bridge he's never coming back to
that office which his work was his work
stays though right i mean all the work
yeah yeah yeah yeah but he'll never come
back right he'll he'll never come back
to this situation no because of this
letter that he's written so let's say
that so this is step two this is uh
scenario two they they go with the new
prosecutor they bring the full evidence
now they make the presentation and they
get the grand jury to indict which
frankly
they're going to be able to get an
indictment there's an old joke about any
prosecutor worth his salt could indict a
ham sandwich and that's kind of what
pomerantz might be saying is that what
he's saying here or is he going way
beyond yeah he's give it to me let me
get let me in coach i can get an
indictment with the grand jury why are
you hesitating why are you pausing and
and alvin unfortunately he was a popular
pick
in the when he was elected but he's just
done terrible terror he's shown terrible
terrible
political judgment and professional
judgment since january it started with
his first day memo which he sent out and
said people were all able to interpret
as i'm gonna be light on crime
which is a terrible
you got mayor adams who just got elected
on i'm gonna be tough on crime i'm a
former a former cop and i need to clean
up the city i got to be batman
and then you have the d.a uh heart that
the harvey dent as it were not very hard
not not being the harvey dent right
right right i mean when did i move to
gotham i didn't realize that
right so that was a terrible and that
literally was on his first day and he's
gone downhill ever since and now you got
the governor who's got to worry about
her own political fortunes
because she's a democrat even though
she's a conservative democrat and i
think she's going to have another her
chief of staff's going to call another
meeting with alvin brack after this new
york times article we may or may not
hear about that meeting but i think we
will
and then we got to worry that if they
get the indictment it's been so
dented and scratched that when it goes
before a judge
it's going to give for shetty mileage to
argue that the whole thing should be
thrown out on a motion to dismiss
well and and and i want to i want to add
one more thing to this letter and i
don't know if pomerantz knows this or
not about our show but he really should
have added at the end of this letter
[ __ ] him you know i i'm just i'm just
saying that maybe maybe we could uh you
know scratch that in here and make a
graphic here where it says [ __ ] them
because that's basically what he's
saying in this letter is like look you
have the evidence he's done crime it's
clear-cut all of our work shows this
we will be able to not only not only
slam dunk this i mean he wouldn't
basically write this letter because my
understanding is is when a when a
prosecutor
which he is the special assistant
district attorney here in this letter
that's his title um
when uh when a prosecutor leaves like
this they do not write letters where
they're like there's evidence there's a
crime and the reason why i'm i'm leaving
is because there's a crime normally it's
like some kind of you know soft-handed
oh well thanks for having me but i've
got you know i need to spend more time i
need to spend more time with my family
i'm going on vacation whatever whatever
the hell it is no he went and just to
continue our legal af uh overlap um a
crossover episode here he's gone even
further tony he's not saying
i know i would have gotten the
indictment in front of the grand jury
which is not on the same standard as
having to prove your case it's not
beyond a reasonable doubt it's it's a
different it's a lower standard of
evidence proof when you're just getting
the indictment he's saying not only
would i get the indictment but if i
tried this case in front of a jury
it is beyond a reasonable doubt that
criminal felonies have been committed by
the former president of the united
states and you're not letting me do my
job yeah that's what this letter says
well because the first quote on this
part of the letter i fear that your
decision which he's talking to brag
means that mr trump will not be held
fully accountable for his crimes meaning
and and that's the that's what you're
saying is he's saying here he will he
can be held fully accountable if you
would just do your [ __ ] job he calls
it and he calls it crimes he doesn't say
he's not pulling punches he's not saying
uh potential crimes uh indicted cri
indicted charges he's saying crimes
and you're right you normally do not say
prosecutors are usually more circumspect
more cautious
more but but not when you're leaving
when you're leaving it's like you know
what
just kick everything over let me drop my
drawers and really tell you what i feel
and and not and to your point about it
should say [ __ ] them at the end when i
was a younger lawyer starting my career
and there still were fax machines tony
do you know what a fax machine is i i
have seen one of these uh archaic things
before yet no i know what a fax machine
is using okay when i was in high school
i won't even go into it it was a roller
yeah you actually rubber banded the
piece of paper around the roller and you
stuck it in a cradle okay that was the
facts for me but back in the day
you would write the old joke was if you
were a lawyer you would write something
like a fax a one-line fax that said [ __ ]
you letter to follow oh
oh so that's like the that's like the
intro the the cover page as it were yes
letter letter to follow right and so
that's sort of this except the letter
did follow and the new york times in
doing you know
again just to remind everybody
why we lo well why we enjoy democracy
why we enjoy the first amendment and the
constitution why it's so important
because it's papers like the guardian
the new york times and other
uh investigative reporting institutions
that bring these things to light that
shine sunshine
on these cesspools which will lead to
look some i don't know exactly what it's
going to be you and i have laid out some
scenarios something is going to happen
cause and effect because the pomerantz
letter was published yesterday on the
digital version the new york times well
i i appreciate you joining us and and
one one more thing before we go um how
long is a da's term when they're elected
to the manhattan da's because it seems
to me that maybe mr bragg if he does
make it through
um his coach not firing or the owner not
firing the coach it does seem that he
might have a very bad chance of winning
in so how long is mr bragg's term yeah i
think it's four years right it's not six
i think it's four he's up every four
look i i followed that race very closely
he was not my choice just so to be clear
lucy lang who is now the inspector
general the office of inspector general
for the entire state of new york
selected by governor hochul was my
choice she was also in that office
um and she came in a very very close
fourth it was it was um
ranked voting for the first time in the
in the city of new york so you got to
rank your people and she lost by you
know a handful of votes there but alvin
won alvin had a lot of support he had
the chops it's not that he's not
qualified he is qualified he's been a
state prosecutor he's been a federal
prosecutor he's worked in prosecution
most of his life and he was very well
respected
but he he left his brass ones
at the front door when he when he
crossed into the office back to the
sports analogy he whiffed on this one
let's just say that he whiffed
and and and the people have been
scratching i have to tell you people
have been scratching their head
about alvin bragg and not with joy it's
not like i'm happy that the first black
manhattan district attorney in 200 years
is not doing well i wanted him to do
well but if you have eyes and ears it's
hard to
right it's hard not to criticize the
things that he's done some of it's been
political he he's been a terrible pr
machine for himself and that means he's
not surrounding himself with the right
people who will who will guide him in
that right direction and some of it is
his own judgment i mean
he knew mark pomerance was not going to
be happy about
about uh ending the prosecution he knew
that mark was going to leave and
probably noisily how did he handle that
not well right well i appreciate you
joining us appreciate you giving this
breakdown of what's happening in the
manhattan da's office and everyone go
download legal af
both episodes a week there's the
wednesday episode that you do with kfa
and then the the weekend uh episode that
you do with ben mizellis uh download
that wherever you download podcast or go
to the midas touch uh youtube channel
you can watch it you can watch it there
if you wanna if you wanna watch
um the legal i wanna do a crossover
episode now that you're part of the
midas mighty yeah and a midas platform i
want to do a crossover episode where you
come on our show yeah sure i i would be
happy to come um give my uh [ __ ]
style breakdown of the law even though
i'm not you know an attorney or a lawyer
i would no but you're
i would definitely
say you're a very good what they with
what they would call you in uh in london
overseas is you're a very good presenter
oh yeah yeah well i appreciate that
which we like all right so i'm going to
uh i'm going to run but uh
this is it you you got it breaking news
we didn't even do the legal af version
of this story yet
i'll cut this out we'll try to clip it
up maybe we can get
the suits over at midas touch to put it
somewhere and that way everyone can
watch everyone stick around right after
the break thanks michael polpak
my friend bye tony
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you annoyed by masks infringing on
your rights do you wish you didn't have
to comply with biden's communist mask
mandate are you tired of wearing masks
that actually fit your face
well now you don't have to be
introducing the droop with our patented
droop technology every mask is uniquely
molded to not fit your face just send us
a selfie and we'll have one of our
drupists mold the mask for you elastic
free thanks to the droop i don't even
need to pull my mask on anymore it just
sags that way the droop lets you
customize from a selection of pre-worn
masks lipstick stains included make sure
to order your droop today drew be the
spread you want to see in the world
catch tony's twitch stream the [ __ ] list
roundup at twitch.tv slash the tony
michaels
we're back to the king of brilliant this
is the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for hanging with us through the
break michael popock from legal af gives
us a breakdown of what is happening
at the manhattan da's office
in new york when it pertains to
the criminal investigation of donald
trump his family and his criminal
organization that he calls the trump
organization of course uh you heard
popock break down that there's not just
a criminal investigation there's also a
civil investigation inside the new york
attorney general's office but also gives
us a breakdown of what could happen
with
mr bragg
of who could you know uh put me in coach
take him out put him in assign a special
prosecutor there's all sorts of options
here for donald trump to still be held
accountable
um i think i think this is a
an important story
in our justice system and you know if
this doesn't [ __ ] piss people off
out there that shows
that
celebrities famous people politicians
rich folk pretend billionaires
get a little special treatment
and what the average folk get out there
i don't know what will
what will convince you
um
this is the um you know going on a lot
of people were commenting
as we were talking there with popak
um
we get uh
dude thank you for joining us everyone's
here holy moly we got a lot of folks
here from facebook again we're we we go
live every single weekday noon eastern
11 central right here on youtube
twitter and twitch and now we're on the
midas touch facebook page live
really live like this microphone's on
right now i'm talking into it you're
hearing it that's how live it is
now we have an interview coming up this
afternoon that we it now are some of our
interviews are pre-recorded i will tell
you that so you'll see you'll see when
we uh do the interview with bad brad
berkwit the host of the bad brad burke
with chill i'll change clothes and the
reason why is because we record a lot of
those extended interviews that way gabe
our executive producer and co-host
can do the editing and make it all look
fancy you know stuff that i can't do
live i mean i try i try to do the fancy
thing
with the with the titles and the and the
cuts and the go to this and go to that
you know i try but i'm not the greatest
producer in the world i'm the host and
the producer here so i'm trying to do
both things at once but but that's why
we record some of these interviews and
today we have bad brad berkwith last
week we had anthony scaramucci the mooch
and go watch all those interviews on the
youtube channel don't forget to
subscribe to the youtube channel if you
want to go back and re-watch some of
those episodes
just go to
thetonymichaels.com or search the tony
michaels podcast
on youtube
and you can also go to twitch
we're over there as well now twitch is a
little different story you know the
videos don't stay up there the whole
time they do on youtube they live
forever as the internet says the
interwebs
say that's the quote i guess
you put it on the internet it lives
forever
so like subscribe share
give us a thumbs up retweets you know
whatever whatever whatever social media
platform you're on
and speaking of uh
retweets also follow us on twitter at
tony michael's pod we will have the
bonehead of the week
poll this afternoon we're waiting until
this afternoon because we know they're
just
uh with this with this judge brown
jackson hearings
we know there's going to be some
boneheads that are going to pop up we
just want to make sure we give everyone
their fair shot all the boneheads get a
fair shot here that's what we want we
want everyone to have equality and
equity in the bonehead of the week polls
so go follow tony michael's pod if
you're on twitter you'll be able to vote
this afternoon we'll tweet that out and
for bonehead of the week and then
tomorrow in the second hour of the show
on fridays that's when we do this on
fridays on the second hour of the show
we do bonehead of the week where we
break down your vote
you voted and we break down the vote why
those uh boneheads were on the poll and
then the dishonorable mention and if we
have an alpha cuck
that
day
well look look at here we have uh gabe
our executive producer and co-host
joining us gabe how are you
good yeah well she's talking about
bonehead of the week we're trying to
figure out
it's going to be really difficult this
week i feel like you've got ted cruz
lindsey graham uh josh josh holly
blackburn right
you know it just keeps going on and on
and we only we only have three
we only have three and a lot of people
you know for all those uh people out
there that are just new listeners
it gets kind of confusing with the poll
bonehead poll we we do three
for a reason we don't want to have too
many because we got to kind of constrain
it for the show and everyone always
wants to all the above we've kind of
went through this before where we do
like we you know we have three and then
everyone wants uh all of the above
selection like a four house
we can't do it the problem is is all of
the above would always win like always
there would never be a situation where
all the above doesn't win i mean i
that's my that's my perspective of it
yeah i think uh
it's
it's an easy i don't want to call it a
cop-out but it's an easy uh selection to
be like oh they're all bad it's like yes
we know they're all bad and we know
they're boneheads right this is where
they remind you to tell us which is the
worst or rather the best bonehead
uh at the end of it so yeah it would be
easy to just be like all right cool yeah
all of them but no no we want you to
select one and yes i know it's difficult
right it is hard there are difficult
choices we have to make in life and this
is definitely not the most difficult
there is but
just pick one please well and sometimes
it's really hard for us to decide like
who to put on because i kind of leave it
up to you a lot of times like what do
you want to be on the list yeah um
because who knows we only got two other
slots too we've got dishonorable mention
right exactly so and sometimes sometimes
it's clear who the alpha cuck is right
right like right now i might say josh
hawley right the alpha absolutely 100
uh he definitely is is in the running
for alpha that's why you might not see
him on the you might go to the bone in
the weak pole and be like what the [ __ ]
where is senator josh i can't figure out
how to kiss my wife holly
where is he
in this list and it may just be the
alpha cuck of the week you never know
yeah because we have the dishonorable
mention and we have the alpha cuck right
um and the reason why we added those
past the poll is because what we found
out is this new cycle of boneheads
happens so quickly that sometimes like
by the time we get to the second hour on
friday we're like
well we need two more slots to talk
about these idiots
so we created these two uh like wild
cards that we could just throw in there
so that everyone knows that hey we
didn't forget about this [ __ ] there's
technically five people right in the
race right now two of them just got an
automatic medal for something right and
then the other three are actually
competing against each other right right
and you guys get to vote that's the you
know that's what i like about the
bonehead since we started it is that
it's like practicing voting right like
right yeah you're voting for [ __ ]
but you're voting for who is the
shittiest of the [ __ ] right it's
just the opposite when you actually vote
you don't wanna
[ __ ] out right right exactly just look
at and be like oh gotta do the opposite
got it gotta go gotta gotta make sure i
don't vote for the bonehead on this
ballot right now right right don't do
the bone end of the week voting when
you're actually on an actual ballot but
it is it is practice for democracy right
right right exactly we want to be
democratic here and we go by the vote
everyone knows the votes out there we go
by it whoever ends up winning is the
winner sometimes we've been surprised by
the winner but most times we're like
yeah that's not really yeah though a
couple weeks ago we did have one it was
point one percent right different who
was it was desantis
and
who was it
it's hard to keep track of these these
races was it desantis and trump is who i
think that's who it was
no
um hold on let me i'm looking it up
right now it is tough and and um
gabe always finds the best pictures so
if you're listening out there to the
podcast if you are a podcast listener on
the directories whether you're on apple
or spotify or google or iheartradio
whichever directory you listen to the
podcast on don't forget to leave a five
star review by the way but if you are
listening out there what you miss is the
great pictures that gabe's finds
sometimes of these people like marjorie
tater green or donald trump or
ron desantis
so you might want to make sure that you
don't miss the episode
on fridays because it's in the second
hour the bonehead on friday
um
again we start every single weekday noon
eastern 11 central the good news is if
you miss it live you can always come
back and rewatch it on the youtube
channel so don't forget to subscribe to
the youtube channel but all of you out
there listening to the podcast
you should come watch at least that part
of the week because
um the the images
that we have
i only find the best images oh yeah
that's the best i don't know what voice
that was that was like an attempt at
trump and then it was like this it was
like rhonda's you it was like you were
trying to do a bad impersonation of
ronda rousey
trying to do trump yeah exactly maybe
maybe it was don jr impersonating uh ron
desantis impersonating trump and you
were impersonating right like i mean
any time all you got to know is whenever
don junior walks through him he's always
like joe biden
joe
do you think he practices that in the
mirror
like yeah i think so i think he
definitely like because remember i mean
the guy you know he he's skiing the
slopes you know every morning he's like
you know going down those going down
that fresh powder
and he's in the mirror and he's like
camera one camera two camera one
camera two and then he's like doing
their nostrils he's like playing
he's trying to clear the nostrils and
then i think he honestly looks at and
he's like okay cool all right we got
this looks great i look totally i look
totally sane and then he's like and he's
like
joe biden
right
in that's the jack jack do you think he
notices that he has the
the jack jaw going he's hey yeah yeah
yeah
most people on
certain
drugs
don't always realize
they've got
anything going on they got
yeah nothing going on now uh i can say
maybe by experience
don't know
uh
that
grinding can happen okay there's like
teeth grinding right and i don't know
what it is uh
but that is something that happens
and you're not always aware of it right
and
um unless someone calls you out and says
it it i think it it's like a
subconscious thing that happens like
sometimes
well i i've never done cocaine well i
mean knowingly like that i know of i
mean i i i've i've been young before
right you know there are sometimes you
are inebriated at a party and maybe
there was maybe there wasn't i not i do
not know that i have ever done cocaine
coke um i have participated in some
other you know recreational activities
but never cocaine specifically so i
don't know exactly the effects that it
has on you um but don junior seems to
have more than
normal effects that someone who just
recreation i mean you know there's
there's abuse and there's recreation i
use a lot of times
recreational use of
said uh drug cocaine cocaine uh
please no one arrest me uh
um i think you're well past the statute
of limitations yeah am i it was
yesterday no
no but what i will say is yeah there's
uh
i i personally am not affected as much
as other people uh just the way that my
body is it's very odd with like
stimulants like same we the same way
when i took um adhd medication and other
things right it was just like
you know it is what it is which is
ritalin right which is kind of like well
there's different medica there's like
non-stimulant and there's stimulants so
you could take yes ritalin is one form
and there are other there's concerta and
there's like a ton of other ones out
there now um that you can take i no
longer take it anymore i just learned to
you know cope with my uh my adhd and my
random what you know kind of uh squirrel
yeah uh but it it's one of those things
where
like i know people you know they're like
oh i get the drain which is like it you
know like mucus will fall back you know
and it'll get like draining
nasaling congested uh you know one one
nose versus the other gets stuffy you
know especially the morning after
uh
there's like a lot of things that happen
but
yeah it sounds like sounds like a lot of
side effects and it seems like it seems
like uh don jr it's not really a side
effect it's more like a personality
trait for this guy yeah here's the thing
i think that like don jr
uh is an [ __ ] right he's a complete
douche the drugs are not an excuse
for his behavior right right the drugs
don't make him a douche yeah he's always
a douche and an [ __ ] the drugs don't
make him that way the drugs if anything
just kind of bump it up a little bit and
when i say bump yes
i do mean bump so i think it just kind
of like you know it's a little bit of a
jolt but it just like it's just a little
bit of an uh amplification on his
already
uh [ __ ]
behavior and in personality right right
he's a terrible person just a coked up
[ __ ] as well yeah at this point well
um we actually go through some you know
what i will say this he gives cocaine a
bad name yeah
do you think he likes him like his bag
of coke he's like no i think
no i even i think coke looks at don is
like oh [ __ ] not again
right and i think at the end of the day
if you were to have like a sit down
interview with a bag of cocaine the
cocaine would be like yeah i've tried to
get a restraining order the guy is
obsessed with me we're talking stage
five klinger cannot get enough is always
pulling me out and doing what he wants
with me
that's if i if i would imagine what
cocaine would talk like speak about
right now that would probably be their
feeling about don jr right very forceful
and takes what he wants i i think you're
right i think you're right speaking
speaking of [ __ ] um we talk about a
lot of [ __ ]
in the interview with bad brad berkwith
because um bad brad birkwood has a
special way a special new york way of
saying things
and talking about these [ __ ] and
dragging these [ __ ]
through the mud and we are very excited
to have bad brad on the show today um
we've got the interview ready here and
you actually went on bad brad show last
week uh he did an interview so everyone
go check out
brad's youtube channel and you will find
some very very very um personal nuggets
about gabe um you can find some he he
gives he gives some things away that you
might not know there are some things i
didn't know about you um to be honest
there's plenty more you know someday
maybe we'll do an ama and people can ask
questions yeah maybe and uh yeah well
you know i i was really disappointed
that brad did not ask you about your
soda streaming habit but
i i'm i'm just you know i know i love
sodastream if someone wants us on the
audience i don't want to just rub my
nose like that
listen if someone i love social media
i love it if someone wants to send
us sodastream
uh paraphernalia i don't know why i said
paraphernalia i'm just on this drug
right i know well is sodastream now like
have you replaced your cocaine habit
with the soda stream is that yeah maybe
you maybe we should send stuff to don
junior maybe we could free up his right
bag of cocaine well i'd be afraid he
might he might you know
try to macgyver that into some other
sort of like high intensity like
like you know sodastream co2 in
carbonated coke right oh whoa that's
crazy carbonated cocaine yeah and i
don't know i mean that technically was
coca-cola beforehand you know right
right well it was so go check out that
interview
again he doesn't he doesn't ask about
your sodastream habit but
go check out the interview there's a lot
of a lot of things about gabe that you
may not know that you want to know
definitely for sure want to know so go
check out that interview on bad brad's
uh youtube channel
bad brad berkwitch show on the rings
he's the ceo of ringside report uh so go
check out his website at
ringsidereport.com
stick around right after this break we
will interview bad brad right after this
break hang in there
[Music]
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny
we know what you would do you'd reach
out and give that true american a hand
now here's your chance for only 50
dollars a day you can help us help those
true americans recover from biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those trump supporters and this is that
moment
send your donation via venmo to the real
president donald j trump
it's only fifty dollars a day
recurring and it means you'll get these
trump supporters the critical help they
so desperately need to survive under
this false regime
please donate now because those trump
supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
catch tony's twitch stream the [ __ ] list
roundup at twitch.tv
slash the tony michaels
we're back to the king of brilliant this
is the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome back from the break everyone
appreciate it uh sticking with us we
have a special guest today bad brad
berkwit from the bad brad berkwitch show
brad thank you for joining us how are
you today i'm doing well thanks tony hey
gabe what's up buddy hey
good you i'm doing well
dude oh we're we're doing fantastic i
watched the uh interview that uh you did
with gabe um justin
gabe gabe sanchez
is that your last name gabe who yeah
i should rebrand it to gabe
yeah yeah just change it i am gabe who
exactly
no no i i enjoyed i enjoyed the
interview there was a lot of things that
uh i learned about gabe that i did not
actually know um from the interview
which is good
um you know a lot of things that i'll
probably hold against him
so you know oh yeah absolutely why not i
i kind of you know i kind of give him um
wow i spoke so highly of you i know i
know i didn't see that part i just i
actually knife right in my back i
actually cut that part and i i've been
replaying that part over and over and
over you've been playing you've been
playing if you're a kid so you're like
listen to this guy he's not gonna
respect exactly when he goes on his
walks right before he says [ __ ] him he
listens to you saying oh he's a
beautiful human being and he says yeah
very empathetic [ __ ] yes right so
so brad you do you do these 360
interviews and you've had you've had a
lot you had mary trump on your show of
course event auntie scaramucci that's
kind of how uh we got connected with
anthony is through you and i really
appreciate that um but you've done
you've done a lot of other big
interviews but not just in politics in
the world of boxing because you have
this website called ringside report i
believe it is yes and you came from the
boxing world but tell us i i enjoy your
360 interviews we're more of the shoot
the [ __ ] here you're much more
structured so tell us about those
interviews tell us about yourself now
introduce you introduce yourself to our
audience
okay
i was actually born a poor
non-loving trump child no
you know a movie that's from you know
what gabe you know a movie that's right
uh
right the jerk remember jerk oh yeah
we're in the media yeah yeah
so
you you hit on it with the boxing stuff
uh
first and foremost i'm a new yorker if
you can't pick that up in the in the
forget about it right in the pinky ring
and i do that shtick because i don't
want people to ever think that i'm from
northwest indiana
because my better half debbie got a job
working at british petroleum in white
indiana but the minute
she retires i'm pulling up with the dogs
in the u-haul truck and we're getting
the f out of here i'm trying to recurse
too early into the thing no no you can
curse all you want i know i know
are you are you going back to florida
then is that the is that i don't know i
i would love to go back to new york but
i'm trying to stay away from cold
weather so actually it's funny you said
it because on the way back from i took
debbie to pt today on the way back she
was like you know we need to figure out
where we're going to retire to after
this and we're like texas is out because
abbott and all them are such [ __ ]
even though it's about 10 15 years down
the road but we have to see where these
states are at at that point so i'm not
sure where we're going
baby
and we talked about california the only
thing is with california so ridiculously
as you know well it's so expensive i
mean i don't even understand why it's so
damn expensive out there i visited there
in 2011 and it's just insane but i'm not
ruling it out because i do love
california and it's good for the
entertainment industry but
you hit on it you talked about boxing
um
born in new york
moved to florida my parents divorced
when i was seven years old in
1975. lived in florida lived in new york
that's the two biggest places before i
joined the military uh in 86
and you always said we say 20 years and
28 days and for your viewers that say
how the [ __ ] is it 28 days brad you're
exaggerating no let me explain it
because i've had to explain it before
i came in september 2nd
1986
and i retired september 30th 2006. so on
my dd214 that all of these patriots that
aren't that don't know
and attack the [ __ ] capital on
january 6th
it's what you get when you retire or you
get out the military 20 years and 28
days
during the gulf war with papa bush
i was in country i was uh flying
missions i wasn't a pilot but i was
flying classified missions and then uh
the iraq war i was in the pentagon under
papa are under bush junior so that's
when you see me say war and peace it was
war and peace because you you guys know
my line if you don't i'll say it for
your viewers for all those [ __ ]
that attack the capital and that are not
patriots who always want to talk about
colin
uh kaepernick uh offended us which he
did not offend me one bit as being a
retired military
most of those people
tony never even served in the [ __ ]
salvation army right let alone the
united states army but they have an
opinion
on my service and i don't speak for all
veterans i only speak for me i know how
this veteran feels and the shadow box
behind me is my life in the military so
i i come from a um a place that i can
talk on these type of things where these
people on twitter or marjorie taylor no
bobard had lieutenant corporal there's a
[ __ ] such thing she took an officer
rank and enlisted rank and put it
together so i if so i was a petty
officer first class so i think i'm going
to be a rear admiral petty officer
there may have been there may have been
someone who did a video about that i
don't know it's possible
yeah of course gabe did a video about it
yeah it was a facetime call with uh bobo
okay okay yeah we'll send we'll send
that over what's in that absolutely i
gotta say and then the boxing side was
uh my father got rested so turned me
onto boxing 1975 again when i was seven
and from 80 to 83
i was an amateur boxer uh down in north
miami beach florida and i fought all
over florida and so on we'll probably
talk about that later on i want to get
ahead of you but um so that's where the
boxing stuff comes in and you're right
tony like i said the shirt i wore for
you guys today there the heart of boxing
uh
ringsidereport.com but
it's not just boxing anymore like gabe
talked about yesterday and i concurred i
never expected to be in the position
that i am now but when trump got elected
i changed my show i made a comeback
um in the height of covid and i went
from strictly boxers
to
political people
entertainers but more moving humanity
forward which is my tagline
and talking about trump and what's going
on in the country so my my show has done
a a complete 180 from all boxers and
i've you know been in this game for 25
years so
i'm more set now going in the direction
i am still another sport of boxing i
don't like where it's went with all
these [ __ ] pay-per-views or the paul
brothers fighting floyd mayweather one
of them that's all that's as we say it's
a fugazi it's all [ __ ] that's not
conor mcgregor when floyd fought conor
mcgregor went to 50 you know he carried
him the fight was fixed it was a joke so
that's the boxing side you got a
ringstar report
but ringside report as well is um
politics world news entertainment social
issues and our hashtag i got a very
diverse writing team is hashtag
moving humanity forward like you guys
are doing on your platform that's what
it's all about well we appreciate them
we appreciate you being in the fight for
your service in the military and your
service to your country after i i think
i think um some of the interviews you do
are are absolutely fantastic you take
deep dives um into those interviews i
i've watched
i went back and watched several i
actually that's how i did a little bit
of uh research on um anthony scaramucci
is is it went and watched is went and
watched your your interviews that you
had
now
um i want to get to a clip of your
father because you brought up your
father here a minute ago
and i think that might have a lot to do
with
um why you entered politics but before
we get to tell me tell me
what made you go from
hey it's just strictly boxing because
you were originally like a writer right
not necessarily no i don't know
i was a yeah i was a journalist i
started in the game in 1997. so 25 and
quarter century now um and i was writing
about boxing i made my bones doing
boxing interviews george foreman kenny
norton chuck wettner you know angelo
dundee who trained ali who's behind you
knocking out sunday yeah yeah i want to
i want to ask about that story too yeah
yep so yeah i started there i was always
i always fought for social issues
but i did it in my circles i never
tolerated racism i never tolerated
discrimination against women and stuff
like that but i didn't get into the
political side
until
donald [ __ ] trump and i was like
that's it i can't do this no more
like i said covet hit
and
my dear friend marielle trump said hey
you got to do interviews on zoom because
i was doing them i used to do them on
the phone dude i used to do them where
i'd record them from cassette and type
them back and take hours and if you had
a long interview it's three hours of
transcribing so
then we went to debbie and i created the
bad brad birkwood show when we were in
oklahoma
and i was interviewing local mma guys
because it kind of branched down to mma
too
boxing but when kovit hit and i couldn't
interview anybody anymore in the house
because i had a office slash studio my
earlier shows was all fighters
i made a comeback with mary mary was one
said hey brad you got to do them on zoom
and once you do zoom or like this
platform or trip it opens up the world
which it did because as you guys have
done i've interviewed people in scotland
and england and canada and all over the
united states so this is the format that
i'm going to stay stain unless i ever
get picked up and they put me in a
studio somewhere and you know i don't
edit i don't do anything anymore and i'm
just in front of the camera but that
that's how it that's how it started for
me to get into the political side i
couldn't i would cover it i saw trump on
the tv every single [ __ ] day put a
light up your ass and drink bleach and
all the stupid [ __ ]
dr fauci who i have much respect for get
attacked because of trump
that is what got me into the political
part the activism side was there
because of my father which will show the
clip yeah that side was there fighting
for uh native americans uh speaking out
on behalf of the african-american
community i'm in an interracial
relationship my son is is biracial so
that's always been there that part
because that's my dad that's my father
and me but the political side came with
trump
right well and i i want to play this
clip um that shows you're dead now this
is this is kind of a a famous clip in
that it was in the movie milk correct is
that our part of it was yes yes and i'll
tell you i'll tell you the story however
you want me to yeah
yeah
tell us tell us a little bit about your
dad before i play the clip and then
we'll play the clip and then maybe you
can tell the story about how it came to
be that you even knew that this was in
the movie milk yeah tell us a little bit
about your dad yeah so my father god
rest his soul stood 5-2 he was joe pesci
before joe catch me
and that's
everyone's going to see that in a clip
you're dead you're dead now his name is
alvin correct
yeah he he definitely is uh predates joe
pesci uh like like i think they actually
modeled a lot of joe pesci characters
after your dad maybe well my dad
everyone sees the clip to understand
yeah well my dad actually acted he
didn't make it big big i got all those
acting pictures in my house framed on
the wall but he didn't have the patience
to deal with and gave you notice to get
in the sag and all the ass kissing and
he went to jerry lewis all kinds of
stories doing the show but he tried to
talk to jerry lewis who was in charge
one time i think he might have been
president couldn't get in so he left
hollywood
but he still had that little you know
that joe pesci you know you got
something to say to me you know that
type of stuff so
that clip
he took on anita bryant who was very
famous in the 1970s
speaking she was she was against the gay
community my dad took on any cause
whether it was for back then and he says
in a clip where do you see a negro on
his beach tell me and in context that
was 1977. so that's what you know back
in 37 they would say the word negro now
we say african-americans but he fought
for african-american rights he fought
for gay rights and that clip is anita
bryant
took her on
they kicked their ass
on miami she had a thing that they were
trying to say if a teacher is gay and
teaches your student
your kid is going to turn gay which is
absolutely unsteady that sounds pretty
similar to what's going on right now
right
in florida believe it or not yes that's
the craziest one
here and yeah and if right full circle
and one thing i do want to tell your
viewers that is a smack in the face of
anita brian if you don't know her story
her granddaughter just married a woman
so that's like a kick in her ass for
hating the game
and she's still talking [ __ ] so that
that's the clip of my dad now yes they
took a piece of it and put in the movie
milk so what happens in 2009 my dad had
been uh have been dead then 11 years
because he died in 98. so i get a call
from west kosovo said hey
i'm pretty sure your father's in milk
i'm like how could he be in milk because
he's passed away
i never thought public footage because
guys i didn't know about this clip
i had to see you didn't know this
existed before
before was in the movie no i i i was
there when he fought against anita
bryant right and i knew about that i
knew when he would protest he had the
signs and all that
excuse me but i didn't know about the
clip
so somebody else hits me up and says hey
i'm telling you your dad is in this
movie here's about the time whatever it
was okay kid you're not you can't make
this up
i'm living in virginia
and i come downstairs to get something
out of the refrigerator it's about 1 30
1 40 in the morning and i turn on the tv
and you cannot make this [ __ ] up hbo and
boom
the clip starts because he wasn't the
only one in the in the public domain
that the footage they use it was ray it
was jerry brown
ronald reagan when he was governor my
dad and then some other schmuck and
actually the guy that's talking at the
end my dad lit that guy up but you
that's the footage you know i got others
so
being in the media
i reached out to somebody and they gave
me a name of the guy that his name was k
is still is he still alive ken rabin
and he actually took that public footage
because the first thing i said you get
paid for it i'm like it's public footage
you can't get paid right right
because it's a it's an mb it's it's an
nbc archive right it's an nbc archive
right now but if my father were alive he
might not be able to get some money for
it but i'm telling you guys my father
was a character he would have had me get
eight by tens he would have been trying
and all of that and and everything else
i get in touch with him he says yes your
father is the one with the hat on and it
was the most dynamic i i cut and pasted
i think i sent you an article where he
said it was the most dynamic footage in
the that we used
so
he says look contact nbc at rockefeller
center and this is the guy tell them i
sent you
they'll they can get you probably that
on dvd well not only did he get me that
he got me the footage that didn't quite
make the tv when the guy when my dad
thought i got to kiss his ass
the guy at the end of that clip in milk
you don't see that in nbc so they used a
little piece of that and the clip that
you have is the whole
piece and that's how i became aware now
this is this is is this a reporter like
from nbc that was filming this do you
know no they did a whole piece no it was
a whole it was not just my dad it was a
whole piece on anita bryant and the bill
that they were trying to get past at the
time i see and it was a whole story that
started out in san francisco because
they had a gay parade and the guys were
in a car in drag and this is like in 77.
well right but but but
how did the how did that how did the
camera get right there in that moment
with your dad because oh because
there was there was nbc somehow i don't
know how honestly i can't answer how
they got there but the movement was so
strong against anita bryant that they
they must have been following them and
they they got my dad and i've done the
right thing i mean i mean that the rant
that you're gonna see is is phenomenal
um and i don't blame any movie maker
anywhere putting this this footage
inside of a movie especially about this
topic um and how they found this i have
no idea but it's it's a beautiful piece
that now it's not the only activism that
your dad did we're gonna show this piece
but there's there's a couple other
videos that you have in your youtube
channel of your dad even like going to
like school board meetings and stuff
like that he he he did not [ __ ] around
like like if he believed in something he
didn't care he would stand there and he
would tell you exactly what he believed
whether you gave rather you gave two
shits or not he would stand there and
tell you exactly what he believed
because he believed it he had conviction
yeah
is that is that where you kind of draw
your because i know you do that on your
show a lot yeah um is that kind of what
you think where you draw from is your
dead 100 i grew up like this my father
taught me that you don't judge i know
martin luther king said it too but he
said you don't judge a person by the
color of their skin but the content
their soul the janitor is no no better
or worse than the fortune 500 ceo and
the guy on the street that may be down
now might have been the fortune 500 ceo
so you talk to people like he always is
saying was you know i always end my
shows with what's the same my father's
it's cliche but it's all one do you want
others as they as you want done unto you
that was the way i was raised
in the third grade i wrote a book report
on native americans
and and we said indians and say native
americans then but indians where they
were treated by this country and
black people
and i had a third grade teacher named mr
stratton that cut me off in the middle
of my book report and said you can't say
that well when my dad found out he went
to the school
and he got the principal in there and
the teacher and he said you will not
this is true you will never
cut my son off again because first of
all it's his book report second of all
what he's talking about you may not like
it as a third as him being a third
grader in 1977. but it's the truth right
right again again full circle happening
right now right full circle right
so yes tony and answer your question it
all comes from my dad it's it's
ingrained in me
to to take up for the underdog and
whoever it was
my father um would take off for the
underdog and at a per you always heard
me say to you guys i said to you
yesterday in a personal cost there was
no social media then they would go to
his car because my dad's side of family
is jewish
my mother's side is italian and my
running joke is
it
when my book came out i always tell
people i said well tell us about stuff i
said well the jewish side likes things
at a discount and in the italian side
are expensive so the jewish side wants
them at a discount
my dad might not be politically correct
but i'm still well you know yeah say it
you can say that
but my dad would walk back to his car
and they put swat stickers on his
volkswagen and where he had to take it
to the paint place to get it taken off
so they or they would attack him and now
my dad would fight back he used to carry
a 38 it could still weapons permit so he
would fight back but at what i said at a
personal cost
and it wasn't just him was people in
that group that wasn't popular you know
a lot of a lot of activism now for the
people that aren't really serious about
it but they're trying to do it just to
make a name but they're not they're
their hearts not in or doing it for bad
or for [ __ ] reasons yeah that's on
social media where it's easy
he did it in person where you get the
[ __ ] kicked out of you or whatever what
happened so yes everything is from my
dad yeah there was no blue check mark
back then that you could cloud chase
you know social justice this is legit
[ __ ] right roll it out what what year
is this clip from that we're going to
show june 2nd
1977 the nbc nightly news it was a it
was a clip it was a whole piece on anita
bryant and it had showed her too because
she said i love the gays or something
like that you know i'm christian and but
you know
that she sounded like mike pence with
boobs
or or well or i was thinking of donald
trump when he would say there's my black
person over there right there's my
african-american that's actually what he
would say that's what he would say
yeah well you know and um i think it's
uh
appropriate that you have the attitude
that you have with trump because he is
the epitome of hating the underdog right
everyone everyone acts like he's some
kind of blue-collar billionaire whatever
the [ __ ] that's supposed to mean but
this guy this guy absolutely looks down
upon every anyone who is not him or
maybe ivanka but absolutely everyone he
looks down upon so let's play the clip
of your dad here real quick
okay but if you're a guy this country
was all negroes and you were what and
they took your rights away from you
because you were white and they killed
you three four and five-year-old
children in churches now what would you
say white man tell me
well that's not where you're gonna sound
the hell it is you think the nickname's
equal where do you feel in this speech
show me
they had signs no dogs in jerusalem are
you jewish
yeah no dogs and jews are like i lived
there when i saw the sign okay it's not
that close where neither brian belongs
to where they don't allow negroes and
jews i like to see you and rabbi webb
and the rest of those jews
i belong to human beings if you allow
one just one human being to be allowed
to have his rights taken away from him
as a human being that pal you don't have
any right when they have to take away
your rights because if you're saying
screw you to them they say screw you to
you and six million more jews line up in
the toilet and i'm not going to wind up
with them
and i'm a jew and i've got that part of
mature and i'll say it's not a joke
a human being
okay
of your dad alvin there the passion like
the
you could just in his eyes you could see
just how much he [ __ ] just like he
cared about it he was serious meanwhile
you know the other schmuck over there
was like okay yeah sure let's just shake
it away you know and they're like i'll
just walk away from him and he's like no
[ __ ] this like i i am i believe this is
where i stand [ __ ] you like it was very
yeah very passionate well uh you got one
hell of a pops there that's that's for
damn sure and and i'll tell you that uh
that for 1977
for a guy his size and for him to be a
jew as he said standing on the street
um to defend
uh people's right to be gay at that time
because i think that's what you're
saying he was he was defending it at
that time oh yeah
um in 1977
as a jew to stand on the street not just
not just to say something but to be
holding stuff in your hand and to be
talking to people and to be out outright
uh vocal about that opinion at that time
yeah that was that was a tough thing to
do that was probably not easy like you
said he would get a lot of pushback um
even in that public space
i don't i don't think a lot of folks
understand
um just how far things have come now
we're not perfect um you know obviously
obviously we're not perfect we have we
we have in the same state that your
father was standing on the sidewalk
there in 1977 we have them now
passing a don't say gay bill um
in that same state which seems to be the
the opposite of what your dad was
fighting for so
um if we could get a little more of your
alvin berkwit energy in florida that
would be fantastic um actually in a lot
of states texas and the like where
they're trying to pass a lot of
anti-lgbtq
community uh bills um where they're
trying to ostracize these people from
society
but um in 1977
that is that is almost i believe almost
as
almost as brave as them being against
these people today because i think don't
don't you think don't you think this is
not a very uh uh popular road for these
fascists to go down like i believe most
americans are like you know i think you
should just love whoever the [ __ ] you
want to love and leave people to [ __ ]
alone i mean rather rather you believe
in gay marriage or not or whatever your
stance is most people just want other
people to be left the [ __ ] alone because
they don't want people to [ __ ] with them
tony this is what i say and i always try
to call it right down the middle
i don't have a problem honestly if you
if if you're if you really are religious
and you go by the bible whatever that's
that's your thing if you have a problem
with uh gay marriage or gay couples i'm
not gonna tell you what your opinion
should be what it shouldn't be but what
i will tell you is if you claim you're a
christian you don't treat somebody
because they're a man loving a man a
woman love it a woman or they're
transgender whatever it is whatever it
is you have no right to treat a human
being less than because you don't you
don't have to like the lifestyle but you
don't have the right to treat a human
being
less than because they're gay it's the
same thing when i say with colin
kaepernick you have a right in america
not the like that he took a knee i'm the
opposite i'm for it i take a knee with
her if you call me right now and said
hey brad i'm taking a knee at seventh
and grand i'm gonna go there with him
come with me i'll take a knee and i'll
let the world know i was in the military
and take a knee with them but i don't
say that people don't have the right
to not like that he took a knee what i
won't allow on my platform or anybody
that comes around me is to change the
[ __ ] narrative of why colin took the
knee right because it's huge and trump
with his [ __ ] about son of a [ __ ]
players and all that is [ __ ] trump
first of all couldn't take a knee
because a fat bastard couldn't get back
up from taking a knee
and he makes the narrative up and they
make the narrative up with them and i
know though you guys know the story
where khan want to get off too much of
it you know the story about it was a
military guy nate boyer said that
but it's not even that again this is
america i tell people they say well what
do you mean
i don't want you to stop the kkk from
marching down the street i'll tell you
why because if you stop the kkk from
marching down the street then the three
of us don't get to march down the street
anymore either what you do is you fight
back against that [ __ ] you speak out and
you use your platform i'm not condoning
to go over there and bash your head in
with a cinder block i know a lot of
people say well that's what we should do
i'm not condoning that okay but what i
am saying is they have the right to do
it because this is america i don't want
anybody to lose the right but we got to
push back on this [ __ ] right and
this whole freedom of speech thing
it goes too far because what these
politicians are doing
with power to me is more than freedom of
speech what fox news is doing is more
than freedom of speech
going back and tying that into my father
my father would be speaking out against
uh tokyo rose and all of these clowns bo
barton he would be at them
every single [ __ ] day i would love i
would pay to see him oh yeah go toe to
toe with these
you know the thing is and i want to
remind your viewers that wasn't
rehearsed i mean i know it all in my
head i could do the thing verbatim
because i've watched it so many times
that was off the top of his head because
as gabe said he felt that right you know
when he said if you allow one just one
human being to have his rights taken
away from them as a human being then and
he said pal because he was a new yorker
that's a new york thing then pal you
don't have any rights when they come to
take away your rights
if you don't understand what he's saying
because he's yelling it then you you
absolutely are clueless because it's the
truth no matter what 77
or 2022 if we allow one african-american
one member of the lgbtq community one
member hispanic community one caucasian
person to to lose
their rights even if we don't like what
they're doing
then everybody's going to wind up losing
them that's right it's a slippery slope
you know it's one of those things i saw
i think it was today i was going through
instagram and a clip came up of
gabrielle union and she was doing a
promo for uh cheaper by the dozen they
did a remake of it yeah yeah yeah it's a
movie on netflix is that right uh disney
i think oh yeah that's right yeah okay
okay but in the clip you know it she's
with variety she's talking about these
rights taken away from the lgbtqia
community and she's like listen if you
think that's just the them problem right
you are sorely mistaken babe like i'm
telling you right now if they can go
after them they will surely in some time
later in the future come after you so
you better defend these these people
this group right here because if you
don't then you're next yeah and that's
you know exactly what your dad was
saying i was saying i can't believe it's
from 1977 to 2022
your dad is down in miami defending
people's right to have their the sexual
identity that they want and here we are
with uh gabrielle union in an interview
having to say the same [ __ ] in 2022 but
here's here's here's the the fact of the
matter is is that you're right with the
freedom of speech and the freedom of
thought just as much as uh you know
you know they'll call us liberals or
libtards or whatever socialist kind
whatever the hell they'll call us right
um
just as much as we're entitled to our
opinion they're entitled to theirs but
where it starts to cross the line is
when you legislate um me and me and gabe
played a video and i posted this video
on dick doc
um from denton texas
uh it's at the university of north texas
where uh jeff younger who's trying to
run for congress he has a transgender
daughter he tried to not have her be
transgender um he's he's a bigoted piece
of [ __ ] this guy's a full-on fascist uh
he even tries to go around different
universities to give presentations and
this that the students at this
university protested him and in the clip
that i posted on tick tock which it's
got a lot of views uh it's got like five
and a half million views uh just on my
tic tac so i don't know how many tens of
millions of views that it has but it's
gotta have a lot because these these
these students are chanting [ __ ] these
fascists
and the one the one comment i get from
all these
they're white supremacists they may not
know it but they are um
i'm serious they may not know they are
but that's what they are right right
they'll say they'll say oh why couldn't
this these students let him have his
opinion he can have his opinion you get
to hold your opinion no one is forcing
him to be in prison because jeff younger
thinks a certain way but what jeff
younger wants to do
jeff younger wants to put people in
prison because they think are are a
certain way and that's what they don't
really understand about fascism about
freedom of speech and and and
oppressing rights is
and i say it all the time it's in our
intro i i the quote is from me the
freedom to oppress the rights of other
people
is not liberty you [ __ ] eating morons
and and let me say it again the freedom
to oppress the rights of other people is
not liberty because we don't really
everyone you know i get this from the
stupid freedom convoy and people convoy
morons they they talk about mandates
they [ __ ] that they can't go get
whoppers because they're not backs all
this nonsense look we strive for liberty
in this country that's what we strive
for the rights and the freedoms are
actually what delivers us that liberty
and i believe a lot of your content is
spot on because
your number one
uh your number one word that you use a
lot is humanity and like that's what i
try to tell people is like
you know you may think someone is out
there you may think someone is weird you
may think their lifestyle is not what
you want you may you may not agree with
everything they're saying
even fascists like i don't agree with
fascist but by god they get the right to
hold their fascist bigoted views they
get to be a racist if they want to be a
racist i mean lindsey graham i think's
the one that was it lindsey graham or
was it was it lindsey graham today
yeah well no he today he was talking in
in the kanji uh brown jackson hearing he
said we uh they're going to say racist
stuff about us or say that we're racist
which is par for the course we're used
to that lindsey graham basically said
he's used to be calling a racist like
well i mean i guess if you have to say
i'm used to that that's par for the
course that's probably a bad sign like
you shouldn't just brush and be like
it's it is what it is it's like no if
people are calling you racist and you're
used to that and you're just like
whatever
we're on a conversation lgbtq right
i can't tell you 100 lindsay graham is
gay but i can tell you 100 that i
believe lindsey gamma is great okay and
this is what i understand about lindsey
and i'm gonna call him lady g cuz i
can't stand them
there's my problem
the republican party wants to get people
in why doesn't he come out the closet
and use his platform and help the lgbtq
community and say hey look we
republicans take a lot of [ __ ]
i'm gay you know lindsey graham's saying
i'm gay
i want i'm going to fight for you no
desantis you're not going to do this in
florida this is wrong because you know
barney frank you know bonnie frank was
yeah
you know but no ah lindsey graham wants
to pretend he's not gay and whatever
whatever the case may be he don't want
to use his platform because he wants to
go with their evil with the evil
[ __ ] of that party
and you would have thought that
when he said in gabe talk and i talked
about this yesterday when he said trump
was he is a zen of
and a homophobe and he's gonna get our
troops killed over there you do a pretty
good lindsey graham you know that you do
a pretty good living [ __ ] scary but
you know he says that [ __ ]
and then he's down there washing his
balls you know might be maybe his golf
balls but watching his bowl golfing with
him now he's wonderful i mean it's it's
it's it's
[ __ ] insane yeah i mean i mean go
ahead i was gonna say it is unfortunate
that you've got you know we kind of
talked with yesterday when you asked me
about like hispanic community and why
they might support trump you know and
kind of the mentality that's there and i
think that's also true with the
republican party is like
the group is known for a set of ideals
conservative values christian catholic
whatever and if you are you know being
gay and religious not okay yeah you know
and so
it is sad and unfortunate that if you
are
you know uh one way or the other that
you have to
um appear as if you are a straight you
know cis you know gendered man and you
you could not be gay you could not be
trans you cannot be this you cannot be
that like you have to
regardless of how you actually feel and
how you truly are you have to put this
image this facade up as i'm a straight
white man or whatever you know and it's
it's it's unfortunate and even if he
were to come out and say that you know i
am gay and i'm part of the republican
community and i will fight for your
rights like
i i could easily see them going okay
let's time to primary this [ __ ]
like that's what it would come down to
because they it's this group this this
peer pressure this group mentality where
they would take over and say you're not
like us
you're out yeah and that's soon it's
like us versus them kind of that's how
they're
the most simple
talking point to that
i'm not a fan of this cheney i i think
they give her far too much credit yes
she's doing the right thing i'll give
her credit with the january commission
adam kisses you're both going to get
i'll give him credit for that 93 of the
time liz cheney voted more with trump
than [ __ ] uh i don't take a bath
[ __ ] jim jordan so
i'm not i'm not with and and
kindergarten and cheney voted for
[ __ ] trump in 2020 after all of that
[ __ ] that he did
okay i wouldn't care if they wrote
somebody in i wouldn't care if they
wrote their own name in i know they
weren't going to vote for president
biden that's your right that's fine but
not this [ __ ] trump
they if you tell the truth in the
republican party you're [ __ ] out
right yep the truth just the simple
truth that that was the insurrection
because that [ __ ] [ __ ] don't you go
ahead and ask me something about it i
feel about veterans because you know i'm
what i'm gonna say
about january 6th was a [ __ ]
insurrection and they told the truth
about it and they're out cheney's out
you got that little [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] pedophile that i've challenged him
to three rounds to get a [ __ ] ring
with me don jr him and [ __ ] crews all
three of them not threatening their
lives cause i don't do that
cherry like i told gabe i'll put a
[ __ ] certain amount up these bastards
put a certain amount of the winner which
is going to be me goes to my charity of
choice it'll go to the lgbtq community
just to shove it up their ass even more
because
they talk on [ __ ] but the truth gets you
out of the republican party the [ __ ]
truth
so elijah if like gabe said if you're
supporting lgbtq oh you're [ __ ] get
across and burn you
you know my mother mother i call her him
penis people like to correct me it's
mike penis because he's a dick
mother penis
teaches
at a school that doesn't let gay kids go
there yeah but you're christian
right right it's a christian well you
know uh george carlin speaking of new
yorkers and christians and the lgbt
community george carlin once famously
said that who who other than uh
homosexuals have less abortions these
two people should be natural allies
christians and [ __ ] he said that in
one of his bits i believe it was in
1994 if i am correct okay that's when
george crowley george garland
but but you know
i don't understand why
that the republican party couldn't um
you know broaden their tent to and
welcome these other than their bigotry
but but they you know you and you and
gabe actually talked about this on on
your interview with gabe you talked
about how they kind of courted the
latino vote where they really have
tapped into the conservative ideas and
you know originally that was lindsey
graham's
idea back in 2008 when obama had won and
basically swept the latino vote um and
the republican party did this uh autopsy
and they found out that uh latinos don't
like the republicans that much and um
lindsey graham actually did an interview
and i forget
with who but i'm sure it's out there
that could be pulled where he basically
said
you know he used to be for immigration
reform lindsey graham did like he was he
was one of the proponents he was quote
unquote with the maverick john mccain
on some of the immigration reform he was
more progressive when it came to
immigration you know the republicans
kind of torched him for that a lot um
but he actually said there's
these these people
coming to this country
they're more conservative than some of
the white conservatives that are here
they're natural allies to the republican
party but you know i think that is the
actual rub that we have here is it's no
longer about ideas it's no longer about
ideology it's only about power it's only
about pure power to trump and the trump
allies and they'll do anything say
anything to hold power it has nothing to
do with legislation right there's
nothing to do with policy no and you
know you mentioned lindsey graham
all jokes aside i mean i could do a
[ __ ] 10-minute skit at him but all
jokes aside
this guy's not a good person for example
you you said the maverick john mccain
right he him
and and uh joe lieberman who was the
vice president nominee
for uh for gore
were supposed to be the three of them
were the three amigos they were supposed
to be like this
so
trump lowers the [ __ ] flag when and
and i like john mccain i didn't like his
policies but i respected the man i knew
him not personally but i had some
dealings with him actually believe it or
not with the boxing side because he was
a big boxy fan and he got the muhammad
ali act passed under his watch
so
lindsay was supposed to be great friends
with him when donald trump treated him
like [ __ ] lindsay didn't come to his
defense didn't come to his defense at
all he was also if you know that you
guys are probably noticed you remember
when i believe it was john mccain
lindsey graham and i think hillary
clinton went overseas and did that tour
i forget what it was but they're pretty
sure it was the three of them he he was
friends with hillary now you can have a
difference of policies we could argue
that night and day but if she's your
[ __ ] friend you piece of [ __ ] she's
your friend but you're letting this guy
say all this horrible [ __ ] about her
because whether you like john mccain or
not
the man had integrity i'm sure people
say no he didn't yes he did because when
he stood up that lady at that debate or
not the debate at that speech and he
said she said president obama uh he
wasn't president that he's a muslim or
he's an arab but whatever the hell she
said it was so [ __ ] yeah i think i
think even she got to the point where
she thought he was a terrorist maybe
right yeah he said he grew the mic from
her he said no ma'am he's not he's a
good man he's a family man if i didn't
he said if i didn't think i'd be a
better president then i wouldn't be
running or something paraphrasing what
he said he stood up for him because that
was the right thing to do
lindsey graham and all of them they let
donald trump say the most vile
narcissistic misogynistic
racist [ __ ] and like i told i think i
told davis whoever it was i was talking
to recently
you don't get if they like you tony and
you're a racist but you you say funny
things say well i like the funny stuff
he says but the racist stuff i don't
like that right they own all of me
all of you and i don't mean owen as in
we're we're a slave or or property i
mean
the person you don't get to pick and
choose what traits of donald trump you
like or you don't like you own it all
and with him everything's [ __ ] up so
you're even worse to me yeah you can't
yeah that we were talking about
yesterday when we did the interview and
it's yeah you can't pick and choose you
can't nitpick and be like monday i like
him because he did this but tuesday i
don't like him because he said this
really bad thing but wednesday we're
back on team trump like you can't it's
you own it all like you can't stay no
for one and yes for another and that
goes for anyone you either own it all or
you say nope i'm done yeah i'm not with
him yeah you know i i when he was
president i would ask people you know
that that would quote unquote support
him you know they it may be really you
know publicly they're really soft like
when you're talking to him because they
can sense they could sense my my uh
a little bit of aggression that i had
towards it and i'd be like so what what
is it that you like about him and
never skip the beat he tells it like it
is that's what they'd say and then and
then i'd say in this in the same almost
the same moment i'd say so what didn't
you like about him and they said oh wait
those tweets those tweets i'm like what
the [ __ ] those are the two exact same
things what the [ __ ] are you talking
about it's like you're saying you like
you like that he tells it like it is but
you don't like when he tells it like it
is like get the right out of here the
same [ __ ] people that you're talking
about are the same people you say to him
do you like obamacare [ __ ] no i don't
like that damn obamacare i don't like
that [ __ ] okay do you like the aca hell
yeah you dumb [ __ ] it's the
same thing
right
it's the same group of people like yeah
it's the same really yeah it's it is
insane when you know you call two
different things the same thing it's the
same group of people who will say uh
donald trump should get credit for for
getting the vaccine out he got it he got
it done quick he got it done real quick
and you're like okay cool so you're
going to get it no no so vaccine good
right yeah
he cut through the red tape he got it
done you know and then you're like so
you're going to take it like oh no no it
was rushed it was rushed
and they're talking about you're
absolutely right and to be honest with
you operation warm speed did get this
[ __ ] up pretty fast but how pathetic of
a [ __ ] is trump that his own
team couldn't get him to stay on point
and push it because i'm gonna tell you
something i believe this and i've said
it on my show and i'll stand by it
if trump would have [ __ ] 50 percent
done more for colvin he probably would
have beat biden in the election yeah
because they voted because they hate he
made people hate his [ __ ] guts okay
and that's why you added to me you had
historic numbers come out but if he
would have handled covet 50 not even 100
percent better than what he did
the [ __ ] guy got as you know
about 12.2 more million votes the second
time around after charlottesville after
kids in k after after standing look
what that song [ __ ] said
i believe putin in helsinki in 2017 i
know it's funny what i'm about to say
but i mean what i mean it
they should have [ __ ] gassed up air
force one
left his ass sitting there and said
you're a [ __ ] traitor swim your ass
back to america and when you get back
with 25th amendment your ass because
you're a competitor dan coats i believe
it was the dni or whatever [ __ ] it was
they sat right there in the front row
the [ __ ] jaws hit the ground
that was [ __ ] treason not because
brad berkwith says it was treason right
i don't give a [ __ ] if you hate bush
reagan bush junior eisenhower every
[ __ ] republican since abraham lincoln
you've never seen
to my knowledge
publicly and especially behind a bully
pope and a president of the republican
party say that [ __ ] russia is okay
that i believe putin over our people
that's [ __ ] insanity
about stuff
the truth is as much as they hate the
republicans you have to be [ __ ] fair
show me a republican president that said
that russia and putin
uh in particular was good except you
[ __ ] you got one well i'll i'll show
i'll show you all kinds of people on fox
news i'll show you uh congress people
congresswomen i'll show you senators
i'll i'll show you governors i'll show
you talking heads commentators i'll show
you i'll show you american nazis that
that that purport to be america first
here i'll show you all kinds of them and
the reason why is because that
[ __ ] stood there in helsinki and
said that [ __ ] the reason why those
people that that's that i think you guys
said it last night on the on the [ __ ]
interview that that son of a [ __ ] there
was racism in our country there was
fascism in our country it was all hiding
underneath rocks yeah he just gave them
[ __ ] permission when he came down
that escalator and said that stupid
racist ass [ __ ] and kept on it and kept
on it and kept on it when he was
president when he said that [ __ ] and did
that [ __ ] and then when he purported the
big lie after the election and didn't
actually make sure that this country had
a vaccine delivered which he could have
done if he would have put as much
[ __ ] effort into delivering the
vaccine to this country as he put into
the big lie he would actually have a
[ __ ] legacy today and he doesn't and
that son of a [ __ ]
but you know what the same people were
talking about the same racist [ __ ]
bastards because i don't know if you
remember this when charlottesville went
down there was a clown that they
interviewed and i remember sitting at a
picnic table and he wind up getting
arrested he was talking all this [ __ ] on
social media and then they arrested him
he was mad because he found out he could
not believe that his lord and savior
donald trump allowed his daughter to
marry a jew who was jared kushner this
like like i told gabe yesterday whoever
it was i think it was gay
charlottesville it might have been uh uh
jim uh pinic from uh best in show
this song of a [ __ ] his daughter
converted to judaism or she's got a
jewish name i forget what it is
because jared's family insisted who when
they got married his grandkids are
[ __ ] jewish so how in the [ __ ]
can you say out your mouth that there
are five people on both sides when those
other people were saying jews were the k
word blood and soil which is nazi [ __ ]
they will not replace us so when this
particular guy found out that
he let ivanka his girlfriend marry uh
jared which i don't know how they were
able to do that because i thought they
were he was married the daughter was
married to the father the way they act
he flipped his [ __ ] mind because he's
like she he i'm not cool with that
your [ __ ] grandkids are jewish
and you still place it when have you
ever had a president where they said in
pittsburgh with the synagogues don't
come we don't want the president to come
because he's such and i read it on a
show one time the exact kind of oh i
read it on when i interviewed jordy uh
masalas i read that or it was a journey
i can't remember but the exact words
they asked him don't come when have you
ever seen him not want a president to
come to kind of unite the country and i
don't give a [ __ ] what they say about
president biden the one thing i do feel
even though he drives me nuts when he
says mitch is my friend he's not your
friend the republicans are not your
friends please president biden got a lot
of respect for you but stop the knight
he'll be watching he'll definitely be
watching yeah he'll be i'll make sure
you're watching him
watch he watches our show every year
well you've been you haven't tried the
midas network we got a fifth oh my god
it could be a flip of the coin you never
know it's possible right i love it maybe
maybe please stop saying it maybe
president biden will be a big fan of
ours
you know i i wouldn't i wouldn't mind if
uh if biden tuned in maybe i could you
know like like fox news used to send
signals to trump like tell him what to
say you know i could i just i could just
tell biden what to say and then it would
all be good right
but but one point i was making it was i
honestly believe in my heart that he
wanted to unite the country yeah but you
know when i had anthony on my show and
we did a post uh post-election and
anthony said we got to give the 74.2
million offer him i didn't completely
agree but i understood what he was
saying because if we could peel away
some of them maybe we could get the the
the flashing light like a men in black
like zap their brains and bring them
back to reality or whatever
but you know what we're 15 months into
president biden and vice president
harris's
uh administration they're not coming off
they double down and triple down right
and those aren't rallies to make america
great again or win america back there
for him to [ __ ] griff because
you got a [ __ ] so-called billionaire
which we i don't believe he is i believe
he has money and he'll never starve are
the three of us starving
is starving this bastard will never
starve because somebody he'll griften
and get money right a billionaire
doesn't beg for you to play for trump
force one what the [ __ ] is that
well an actual an actual billionaire
would just buy a new [ __ ] exactly
right they would just buy it or or they
would just charter or they would just
charge or whatever [ __ ] that that they
wanted they wouldn't buy a plane they
just tried whatever [ __ ] jet they
wanted and typically the stan the way
that it goes like after you're done with
your presidency you're like okay cool
like i focus on my library and do that
for the next i'll write a book i'll make
it right i'll do a memoir yeah yeah wait
a second wait a second you guys are
talking about things you're saying
trump's going to write and he's going to
open up
book factory and all kinds of [ __ ] this
is this is it'll be italian the library
but at the end of the day it's like yeah
typically presidents like kind of go off
and do their own thing for a while have
you have you ever seen an ex-president
republican or democrat let's just take
bush jr
you know bush junior is probably
95 against everything that president
obama did right but did he ever open his
mouth not once not once and he was
painting he was painting yeah he was
painting right i know he's hated i know
he
they duked us with the weapons of master
shirt there's a lot on his tab i agree
but he did what is norms you know like
they talk about taxes and going to
inauguration there's nothing in the
constitution that says the president has
to give us taxes or he has to go to the
inauguration but it's norms that we've
become used to peaceful transition of
power we have never in our lifetimes i
guys i've got you guys
by probably between 10 and 20 years and
age
we've never seen an ex-president
act like this and the fact that the
republicans doubled down on his [ __ ]
instead of getting they should have got
rid of him they had the perfect
opportunity to drop this [ __ ]
and if they didn't have if stop this
stealing gabe talked about this
yesterday if stop the steel didn't do it
january 6 if you are a true american and
i'm going to say this and i want to
record because i say that much all the
time
i served that box 20 [ __ ] years and
28 days during war and peace two wars
one in country and one from the pentagon
and any [ __ ] veteran
that was there on january 6 or any
[ __ ] veteran that says that wasn't an
insurrection and talks about their
political prisoners nelson mandela was a
political prisoner stephen biekel was a
political prisoner like that flag that
sent me off that you talked about the
beginning
j6 will never forget you that
[ __ ] are traitors and any
military person that's okay
still with trump and okay with january
6th because they want to see pelosi get
killed or they wanted they thought that
big o don't want to put his [ __ ] feet
up on her desk that piece of [ __ ] is oh
is it american you negate your service
and you defecate on your service and
you're not a [ __ ] patriot you're far
you're anything but a patriot it's bad
enough you support trump still who
called us suckers and losers who treat
us like [ __ ] who didn't go to the
[ __ ] cemetery because he didn't want
his [ __ ] hair to get wet
okay all of it many many things who said
john mccain wasn't a war hero you
[ __ ] that would have ended
anybody else's run but it didn't end
trump and the hollywood access tape
it's not it's the [ __ ] that he said was
bad but the point that people
they stare away from even his [ __ ]
best wife which that's not grammatically
correct drives me nuts talking about boy
the [ __ ] said because he's
donald trump
he could move on them like a [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] rape not because they
were enamored with him because of who he
was he could do what the [ __ ] he wanted
to do and he's got more cases against
him for sexual harassment and everything
else and it just nothing [ __ ] sticks
and if they don't get him for something
and he runs in 2024 i know a lot of
people come to my show say no way brad
he's not going to win again i'm telling
you he got a good [ __ ] chance of
winning because
a segment of this society is [ __ ] up
and they always want to blame the
[ __ ] at these rallies with the
[ __ ] hats on all this [ __ ]
they're not his guys you notice as well
as i do that's not all of his backers
you got a lot of rich people behind the
scenes that don't want nothing to do
with him but loved his tax breaks and
loved what he did with putting kids in
cages but they won't say it publicly
because they don't want to hurt their
[ __ ] brand right right there's a very
good chance that someone [ __ ] could win
in 2024 and because people are so stupid
and they blame president buy them for
the gas prices and for this though no
president has anything to do with the
[ __ ] gas price but they believe it
and they double down on it and they get
news cycles on it
well i what a knockout punch uh from
brad burke which speaking and i don't
mean to switch gears like this but
speaking of knockout punch there's a
knockout punch here that i want you to
tell a story about
um i i have this hanging up here behind
me it's from 1965
it is when muhammad ali
uh knocked out well some say he did some
say he didn't um but i'll let you tell
the story a lot of people uh bring up
this painting
yeah so this so this is one photo shot
of it um i really like this particular
photo shot um when the champ is standing
over him there's a couple other angles
and a couple other shots but this is the
one that i i like the most that's why i
have it hanging up behind me but you
have a special story about this this
picture that i have hanging right behind
me yourself yeah i interviewed angelo
dundee he was very kind to me over the
years i mentioned him in my hall of fame
speech when i got inducted last year he
trained muhammad ali and
he told me that it was a punch he said
brad i know what they said it was fixed
it was this it was that it was a punch
now i know they show different angles
and all of that stuff
but i honest honestly believe angelo and
noah and ali i don't i don't i don't
feel this just might be that ollie would
have taken uh would allow that to happen
him to knock him out because if you know
the whole story when he was the youngest
heavyweight champion when he beat him in
64 at the convention center in miami
beach and and sonny couldn't come out at
a corner they actually put something on
sonny's gloves this is the first fight
and he got in ollie's eye and holly
wanted to catch his clay then he wanted
it he wanted to quit
and he went on he wound up stopping
stunning listen sonny liston was a
monster he was mike tyson back then
without the you know without him saying
robin i love you robin you know he had
he didn't have that
i shouldn't say that because i know mike
you're gonna kill me for this but
i don't believe it was a phantom punch i
from everything that i know it was a
legitimate knockout now uh angelo was
the trainer at the fight too yeah
he was he was there at the so so he
wasn't just at the fight he was the
actual trainer his trainer he trained
him i i think there was only one
fight and i could be wrong about this
that ollie
i mean i'm sorry angelo didn't work
because he had two fighters jimmy ellis
who was from kentucky who was a
heavyweight champion and ollie and they
fought each other and i don't i don't
think i can't remember angela worked
ellis's corner or he didn't work i think
he did him he might have worked elsa's
corner again and muhammad stopped i'm
pretty sure he stopped jimmy ellis
but um
but yeah he was there and that's what he
told me it wasn't a phantom punch so
what when when did you have this uh when
did you talk to angelo about the well i
talked to many times over the years but
i interviewed him i didn't talk about
the phantom punch in my book i don't
think i did but my book is called boxing
interviews of a lifetime i interviewed
him in 2000 uh for my book but i had
talked to him subsequently since then
and i was at the hall of fame with him
in 2001. not not my hall of fame but the
international boxing hall of fame which
is uh in canada new york so before we go
tell us a little bit about because a lot
of people may not know this about bad
brad berkowitz but he is in the florida
hall of fame boxing hall of fame so tell
us a little bit about being what it
means to be in the florida boxing hall
of fame but also i want you to give us
shameless plug of your website where to
find you uh where to get your book if
people want to read it and where to
watch your show okay let me do that and
i'll tell you florida yeah go ahead so
on youtube just type in ringside report
web web tv channel come right up
ringsidereport.com i got a great writing
team there lots of diversity uh all
kinds of articles lgbtq social issues um
you you name it we've got is not just
sports i've got pretty much
sports is the the least of it right now
because what's going on in america i
want put writers together doing all that
um on twitter it's at bad brad rsr and i
always i always interact and uh
so hit me up there as well and like i
said
ringsidereport.com and my personal my uh
if you want to keep up with guests it's
bad brad
berkwith
tuttis.com is my my personal website so
florida
florida boxing hall of fame tony again
my father it all goes back to my father
my father knew some of the legends of
the sport he met cassius clay in the 60s
tried to hustle him on a car that he was
selling
wait wait you're dead your dad tried to
hustle uh cash display at the time that
would i i would actually that would be
great but too bad that footage didn't
make sense
you know what i mean so i don't know if
it was a student i told this this story
in my induction speech he was he was
friends with fighters like kid gavilan
and bo jackie drove cross country with a
very famous fighter named rocky graciano
was championing the world from new york
only problem is they met at miami beach
my dad didn't have a driver's license my
dad still drove at rocky grazie
new york and i always said that and when
he got his license it wasn't much better
because my dad would drive on a [ __ ]
sidewalk
but
i got inducted yeah for
being a journalist for the boxing side
but my amateur boxing journalist my book
oh boxing interviews of a lifetime is
the book it's on all the platforms
authorhouse
authorhouse.com amazon all of them
so
loving a sport from when i was seven
boxing as an amateur 883
and then 1997 making my bones doing
interviews that was the uh that was my
my induction into the office honor of a
lifetime you know i wish sadly i wish my
dad was there he was there in spirit
it's the only part of my speech i really
did get choked up about
debbie was there and you know
debbie is the nucleus behind my show she
she's behind it well she used to be
behind the camera until zoom but she's
the one that you know i bounce ideas off
what do you think it is what do you
think of that she'll send me stuff she's
she's kind of like my silent producer on
all of this but yeah honor of a lifetime
absolute honor of a lifetime well we're
we're glad that even though even though
um you've kind of stepped slightly away
from the boxing world you're still in
the ring side in america right for not
only not only uh politics but democracy
itself because here we we want to
promote anything that's pro-democracy
and uh brad you're always you're a good
friend to me and um uh we we've
talked several times and i i appreciate
having your friendship and and not only
that always come back to the show don't
don't think that uh you're not welcome
back you're definitely welcome back here
uh because uh forget about it right yeah
forget about it
viewers if you really want to see and
gabe you probably noticed for or you
might know it i don't know but if you
ever want to see a great breakdown of
forget about it watch donnie brasco and
watch the scene when paul giamatti who
was a small much smaller actor than now
he's huge he's on millions and all these
shows
he asked donnie
uh
john um johnny depp's character donnie
brasco which based on joe perstone was
the real guy he says what he would
forget about and he explains about it's
a gets a good explanation of because
forget about could mean many different
things right right right right and i
want to say to you guys i didn't get a
chance to tell you tony i know i told
you privately but again congratulations
to both of you guys getting on the midas
touchdown thank
i love that they're they're pushing your
platform out because you guys in your
own your own way and and i love what
you're doing is moving humanity forward
and we need there's more of us like i
told i said it gave yesterday there's
more of us
not everybody's comfortable using their
platform speaking out i'm okay with that
not everybody's made for the life that
we
have completely chosen at this point and
a lot of times at a personal cost but i
appreciate what you're doing and you
know you got my
support but we are afraid like i said i
say i say forget about it you guys say
[ __ ] them that's it [ __ ] em
well thanks for joining us brad everyone
stick around brad you're always welcome
back thank you very much uh for for
being here everyone stick around we'll
be right back after this break
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
[Music]
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker convoy
there's tammy by the time we reached dc
was 50 strong in number
some patriots ran out of gas along the
way
we got plenty of slim jims
skull
near run out natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
circle the city again
here's
bob
dear bob
i'm fixing to send you some more of them
doritos you like the red bag not the lib
loving blue one
in your absence i discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and i
even seen my cousin brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day ears
tammy
[ __ ] em
welcome
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
what a great interview
it's bad
fred bergwit go visit mad brad burke
with youtube channel just type in
bad brad birkwood show on youtube it'll
come up you will see a ton of really
great interviews uh gabe what uh what a
great interview we had with br bad
brad berkowitz
yep
again
[Music]
yeah
bad brett birkway yeah it was it was a
great interview
he holds nothing back and he gets it
clearly from his dad which is like the
original joe pesci the og joe pesci
as it were so great interview always
welcome brad back to the show uh shout
out to brad because he did help us get
that enter that great interview that we
had with another great new yorker uh
anthony scaramucci
you guys can go watch that interview on
the youtube channel so don't forget to
subscribe to the youtube channel
so you can go watch all all of our great
interviews
and all the episodes i believe anthony's
like number 98 i think that's what it is
we're on 103. 103 episodes crazy boy
it's a full week though because we have
the
uh katanji brown jackson the judge brown
jackson hearings going on right now um
but i do want to show one more thing
before we go um
i want to talk about this for just a few
minutes we're 55 minutes in the hour we
got a couple minutes here to break down
what the difference between the
constitution
and the declaration of stupidity i mean
independences
um that's what i tweeted out the um
marcia blackburn obviously does not know
the difference between the constitution
and the declaration of independence she
tweeted earlier the constitution grants
us rights
to life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness not
abortions what the [ __ ] does she think
liberty is
what in the [ __ ] does she think liberty
is this is ridiculous absolutely [ __ ]
now you tweeted here you tweeted i am
not surprised that marsha blackburn does
not know
she's actually quoting the declaration
of independence she does not know that
by the way
i
more surprised that she spelled
happiness correctly are you surprised by
that because she knows how to use
autocorrect yeah like i think it's i
think the phone was like she was like
h-a-p-p-y-n-e-s-s
and the phone was like
nope you mean i ness and she was like no
and it was like you sure
no and then i think
you know there i think the red line
showed up underneath the text enough
times so she was like fine and then
changed it so you know whether she knew
before going into this tweet or whether
she knew up as she was about to send the
tweet either way i'm surprised that she
knows because like you look at the movie
pursuit of happens will smith right yeah
there's a whole it's about intentionally
spelled right right because there's a
whole bit about they spelled happiness
wrong outside the wall of it of the of
the day
right yeah right right
uh so it's like maybe she watched that
movie and she didn't watch national
treasure i don't know you know i look at
this and i'm like you would think you
know john voice the movie he's a maga
head right she's a mag ahead right i
figured
if she watched the movie she would
remember oh yeah nick cage stole the
declaration of independence
they [ __ ] quoted that thing so many
times that movie
they were like oh yeah here's a section
quoted here's a section quoted uh life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness was
one that was mentioned many times and
you would think that you know if she
watched the movie she would have
remembered but then again you know i
don't know
yeah i mean maybe she just had too many
glasses of wine and uh just totally
forgot about it i don't know i i
couldn't i couldn't tell you for sure
how much wine she drinks or what wine
she drinks what i can tell you though is
i have a white one
is it white yeah it's like probably
cheap dry white sheer pure white yeah
pure white like yeah right like suprema
is supreme pure white wine yeah okay i
got you i got you i follow you there i i
smell what you're stepping in as we
would say in my part of the country so
here's the thing
here's the thing that gets me
about marsha blackburn and not knowing
the difference between the constitution
and the declaration of independence i
would almost put a [ __ ] hundred
dollar bill
on the fact that marsha blackburn
if she carries a purse that there is a
[ __ ] pocket constitution that she has
in that son of a [ __ ] so when she's
talking about the constitution rather
she realizes it's the decorations
she pulls it out and waves it around and
puts it i wouldn't be surprised if if if
somebody out there already had a product
that was a half constitution half bible
you know where oh like like a combo
thing yeah like a little like a little
mini book you know kind of thing where
it's patriot bible as it were right
exactly uh patent pending
uh maybe maybe there's a commercial
there's a couple videos i sense
i know i know you're right i need to
write these [ __ ] you need to write this
[ __ ] down what happened what did we just
call it patriot bible patriot what
happens folks is after the show gabe's
like hey what what are those ideas that
we we talked about what what was the
time stamp yeah i gotta go back to the
video clips and go back to the videos we
know uh but yeah you know who knows
maybe there is such thing as a pocket
bible and a pocket constitution that
they love to wave around at people you
know it honestly could be a patriot
bible where it's just like in the front
part
uh it's got the constitution right or
it's got the yeah it's sort of sort of
yeah or maybe it sprinkles it in where
it's like all right here's the book of
genesis
and you know here's the beginning part
of the constitution and then they're
like all right here are the other books
and then you know like or it's between
maybe you get like old testament then
you get the constitution then you go new
testament
i don't know well you know i think these
are all good ideas and maybe maybe we
should
maybe we should check on the url before
anyone nabs it um a pocket patriot bible
and maybe there is a commercial or a
video like an infomercial that could be
made for this product that may or may
not exist yeah but
definitely marsha blackburn
is probably a heavy contender on the
bonehead of the week because she does
not know the [ __ ] difference between
constitution or the declaration of
independence she also does not know how
to use a [ __ ] dictionary
to look up the definition of the word
she's also you know i would say just a
a uh
condescending
uh
is that how you would say that yeah i
mean that's another way to say it i mean
i would say yeah right no totally i
actually i actually use the word no
one's supposed to use the word [ __ ] uh
earlier in a tweet
and and yeah what are you laughing at i
did i tweeted that i know i saw
everyone's like you can't tweet that i'm
like when it comes to marsha blackburn
you certainly can tweet the word [ __ ]
you can tweet it you can say it you can
type it over and over and over again
when it comes to marshall blackburn i do
believe it is appropriate to use that
word i'm just saying and maybe maybe
maybe uh senator blackburn will end up
on
the bone end of the weak pole go follow
he's a very strong champion very strong
very strong so she could end up on the
bone end of the week poll go check that
out this afternoon we will be releasing
that poll so you guys can vote for who
is the bonehead of the week and tomorrow
noon eastern 11 central you will see us
right here on youtube twitter twitch and
now the midas touch facebook page and
tomorrow in the second hour we will go
through your vote your vote on the bone
end of the week
poll so don't miss it
do not miss it tomorrow and until
tomorrow at noon eastern 11 central
surfs up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking